Good morning, John. It's Monday, March 12th. I have something I need to show you
*whispering*
That's awesome.
Freaking awesome.
Thanks, go to [Laila] of bookshelves of doom...
.blogs.com. You can go there and buy amazing shirts from her to support her book habit.
I'm not sure if you can get this shirt.
I think it might just be exclusive to members of the actual brotherhood. We're not like averse to having...
...honorary members of the Brotherhood. There is sort of Hank and John -- we get perks.
Look how big my hands are
Today might be a little bit of a dry episode because I have to teach John how to make a podcast...
...because I can't obviously do it with his video,
so he has to do it too, and I can't send him a text-based tutorial which would be, frankly, much easier.
So I'm gonna have to do it in video blog form.
Yeah, I'm doing a podcast on how to make podcasts. If you're not interested in making...
...podcasts, this might not be your favorite episode of brotherhood 2.0,
However,
I will be throwing in some juicy bits, and you will definitely want to be around for those.
So without further ado,
Podcasting. First step: download Fetch.
Fetch is an FTP program for Macintosh. If you don't have a Macintosh download Smart FTP.
You can download them both in all kinds of places, but I usually use download.com because it is extraordinarily easy to remember.
Thank you for downloading Fetch 5.1 at download.com.
Ohhh my goodness gracious, that's pretty cool.
So we're going to use Fetch to get into our FTP server and then upload something. What something, you ask?
Well of course our
MP4 files which we are uploading every weekday anyways to youtube.
It's important to note here for people who aren't my brother that you can't have a podcast if you don't have web hosting.
Brotherhood2.com is hosted at bluehost.com
I also host stuff at anhosting and midphase; all very good web hosting companies that I would suggest.
That just finished downloading and
I'm opening it so we have now installed Fetch and Fetch wants to know what the host name is. You might think it would be
FTP.Brotherhood2.com, but it's not. The host name is
greenwords.org
FTP.greenwords.org
The username is g-r-e-e-n-w-o-r- The password is the lake where the cabin was, followed by the first four digits of our
old address in Orlando. Go into the public html
folder and then go into the Brotherhood 2 folder.
So now that you've logged in to the Brotherhood 2 directory, you will find a podcast directory.
So basically just drag it on over.. The great news is that you can upload all of your videos...
...just by clicking and dragging, and then dragging all of them over... and go get lunch or something because it's going to take several hours...
because we have a lot of videos already. Now John, once you're done uploading all the files you have to go to
podcastblaster.com
Then go to the podcast syndication tool,
sign in using my email address and the password that we've had since we were like babies. I think you know which one
I'm talking about. You go in there
and then you say create a new podcast. Then you can fill in all the data
Including most importantly the url of the place where the file is now.
So if you've uploaded it to the podcast directory of brotherhood2.com, it will be http colon slash slash
www.brotherhood2.com
slash podcasts slash march8th.mp4 or whatever it is. Then, you push publish,
and you have published that podcast to our podcast RSS feed
Then we just have to publish that RSS feed for everybody to find; we will have a podcast and people who can't get YouTube
at their work will be able to watch our videos. Woo!! I promised you juicy bits.
This is a gigantic picture of me as a baby.
Baby, I have really curly hair, and I'm wearing a Mickey mouse shirt. I am Hank. I'm a giant baby
We're gonna miss you [say]. Juicy bits number 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12...
you can find at myspace.com by clicking on our pictures. Katherine and I did some scanning this weekend!
Hmm! I'll see you, and hopefully your podcasts, in the podcast directory tomorrow.